bonjour mon nom c'est sûr l'an dernier
je suis conseiller municipal je suis
aussi le co-fondateur spéciale en de
fraîcheur
pour toutes les rues qui traverse sainte
catherine ainsi que les ruelles
avoisinantes et entreprennent une
trentaine de murs qui sont repeints par
à peu près une centaine d'artistes une
centaine d'ag rafter est sûre il en
reste d'autres à voir le monde qui doit
faire la cannelle le prochain c'est une
fée celle qui a commencé en 1996 que
j'ai fondé quand j'avais vingt deux ans
et sept festal la bête est née du besoin
de de communiquer avec le public
parce que quand la culture des
graffiteurs nous avec nos visages cachés
en pleine pénurie d'eau ça nous donnait
l'image des rues des vandales à l'époque
et nous on n'était pas confortable que
tout le monde même si tu aimes voilà
quand même apprécier quelque chose qui
est multiple heures en grande taille sur
une mûre ou quelque chose parce que pour
ces gens là c'est une création ce qui
ferait ce que c'est une oeuvre c'est une
murale
[Musique]
je suis devenu de montréalais avec trait
avec beaucoup de visibilité au travers
les 20 23 ans
surtout à cause des graffitis puis
festival les élections qui s'amenait
municipal en 2013 et j'ai été approché
pour devenir candidat je suis parti à
rire et c'est je me suis assis avec les
gens qui m'ont appelé pour les hommes et
est ce que vous connaissez mon
background en gravier tout ça et tous
ces enjeux-là puis on dit ben oui
absolument
j'ai gagné les élections j'étais très
très surpris quand j'ai eu très peur
aussi la soirée que j'étais élu parce
que tout d'un coup le lendemain il
fallait que j'apprenne à gérer un
arrondissement au participer dans la
gestion d'une arrondissement et parce
que dans la gestion d'une ville s'était
jamais aucune expérience politique mais
j'étais un citoyen we had not do in one
is to be done et la mairesse et le
président du comité que joseph monsieur
d'horaires m'ont nommé comme vice
président du conseil municipal
et ça ça vient avec beaucoup de
responsabilités c'est très protocolaire
ces dérèglements quand je te dis elle
était en short ou quelque chose lâche un
chandail à manches courtes avec mais tu
as tout et tout c'est sûr que c'est pas
ça que les gens aient attaquants qu'ils
vont aller lui attend quelqu'un à
cravate en soute bien habillé mais moi
je réserve ça pour mon fonction publique
parce que c'est une question de respect
envers les gens qui
quelle belle histoire pour les jeunes
que je travaille avec eux je vous
demanderai avec que je sais que je peux
même pas savoir c'est quoi ta future
donc la tête 81 16 entre 17 ans et vous
pensez que ce soit votre vie mais je
vous dis que tu peux changer sans même
que tu le saches tu là dedans et ce
après des affaires incroyables donc même
si quelqu'un dit présentement dans ta
vie tu causes des problèmes c'était et
tu vois jamais réussir d'interviews
quelque chose c'est pas à eux de choisir
pour toi c'est à vous à choisir
des élus qui prenait des décisions au
kaki participer à quelque chose disait
j'ai montréal tatoué sur le coeur y'a
pas d'autres élus qui sont tatouées
comme moi je disais la même musée puis
je vais aller me faire justement tatoué
montréal sont d'accord pour lever
quand je prends une action quant à une
décision dont je vote
il ya un impact il ya conséquence et
c'est un peu ce que j'ai appris en
faisant du graphique est elle également
quand j'étais jeune
[Musique]